[Applause]
one of the most underrated aspects of
mass effect 3 was its multiplayer with
all the alien space sex and fantastic
characters it was easy to miss those of
us who did give it a try were treated to
a surprisingly robust experience with
dozens of characters classes and weapons
all of which could be customized Bioware
has confirmed that multiplayer will
return in Andromeda but we don't know
much about it for updates on Mass Effect
Andromeda's multiplayer make sure to
subscribe but in the meantime here are
five things we'd like to see in
Andromeda's multiplayer number 1 crushed
skulls is a Krogan the mass effect
trilogy was always centered around
commander shepard putting the other
races of the galaxy on the business end
of a carnufex pistol pull that trigger
and you're breathing through a new hole
in your head until Mass Effect 3 players
never had the chance to return the favor
as likable as Shepard was we were kind
of stuck with him or her that is until
Mass Effect 3 introduced multiplayer for
the first time in this series history we
could play as a Krogan oh sorry get
turian and many other races from the
Mass Effect universe we know that in
Mass Effect Andromeda story you will
play as either a male or female human
but they haven't said anything about the
multiplayer here's hoping that once
again we will have a wide variety of
races maybe even throw in some of the
new races like the Angora number two
more awesome classes
this one kind of goes hand in hand with
our first point Mass Effect 3's
multiplayer not only lets you play as
different races but it also lets you try
out classes like a Batarian bounty
hunter ag/f juggernaut or add rel
assassin in Mass Effect 1 and 2 if you
wanted to see all the abilities of each
class you had to play through the game
multiple times in three when you
unlocked a new character they came with
a predetermined class what was even
cooler was that classes varied from race
to race and some even had brand new
abilities that not even Shepard could
use for example a vanguard asari had a
different skill set from a vanguard
human the variety was almost
overwhelming Mass Effect Andromeda
single player will allow for more
flexibility when it comes to different
classes so hopefully we see a variety of
diverse move sets in multiplayer number
three where else can you find a volis in
a box one of the reasons I kept coming
back to Mass Effect 3's multiplayer
other than for the galactic readiness BS
was the loot there was a ton to unlock
and most of it felt worthwhile well we
want more of it and we want it to be
meaningful loot I'm talking guns powers
armor sets clothing ship upgrades arc
upgrades and so on and while we're at it
let us bring all that loot to our
single-player story give me more of an
incentive to play the multiplayer rather
than just boosting a meter number 4 meet
your soldiers this one might be a bit of
a stretch but it would be great to
actually see multiplayer characters in
our single-player stories in Mass Effect
3 you could import your multiplayer
characters to the single-player campaign
where they kind of just disappeared
spending hours on a character just for
him or her to vanish was kind of a
letdown it would be great if these
characters could also be seen in the
single player I doubt they'd be able to
join your party but it would be cool to
see them aboard the tempest even if only
for brief moments number 5 co-op
integrated with the story before you hit
that dislike button let me explain
myself we don't want to co-op campaign
or hub areas like in destiny instead I
want to be able to jump into a
multiplayer game from the galaxy map
it's already been confirmed that you can
join multiplayer games from the pause
menu but I'm hoping for a bit more of a
seamless transition if you don't want to
play with others fine I don't
you but it would be great if multiplayer
missions would pop up on your galaxy map
from time to time and if you want you
could join in hopefully all these
missions wouldn't be wave defense
missions either mini raids like strikes
from destiny could be a lot of fun in a
Mass Effect game Mass Effect Andromeda
comes out March 21st on ps4 xbox one and
pc let us know what you'd like to see in
Mass Effect Andromeda's multiplayer and
if you're as excited as I am friend
drama to check out our trailer breakdown
we did for the recent story trailer and
for more videos like this make sure to
hit that subscribe button
[Music]